consider a common source of uncertainty
like choosing a career path suppose
you're in a stable job but you're
contemplating quitting for a less stable
but potentially more fulfilling career
the uncertainty surrounding the less
stable path might set off this process
as follows one overestimation you
overestimate the negative consequences
of choosing the wronger career path like
not making enough money two
hypervigilance you become overly
attentive to signs that could indicate
the success or failure of a particular
career choice like statistics that
suggest that lots of people regret
changing jobs three
identifying the factors that would
contribute to a successful outcome like
doing research on the company you're
considering joining and for avoidance
you decide to put off making this career
decision completely after all it can't
be that bad sticking it out for another
year in your current job the result you
experience heightened emotional
reactions such as anxiety or fear and
that makes you procrastinate for making
a career decision for even
longer